it's the destiny of the human race expressed in
numbers and it's the reason the empire will takeus
they're worried you can predict the future?
they're worried people believe I can and they
don't like the future I predict. which is what?
hey guys Pete here this will be my breakdown
for the first two episodes of the first season
of Foundation the Apple TV+ adaptation of
the classic sci-fi series by Isaac Asimov. they
delivered two long episodes that are dense and
especially in the first one there are a lot
of important details I put together a fairly
comprehensive recap which is also long and so i
added chapters in case you're already familiar
with the story and you just want to skip to the
good stuff as a warning this video will contain
spoilers if you haven't watched the first two
episodes i will be talking about the book series
that the show is based on without giving away any
spoilers for future plot points that come from
reading them with that out of the way let's get into it. if you've read Isaac Asimov's Foundationbooks,
watched my intro videos, or read any of
the press about the TV show then you know
the story spans a long period of time. if not there's
a monologue from Gaal Dornick to open the series
that sets it up. what's interesting here is that it
comes from the perspective of the future she says
that one day she'll learn the name Salvor Hardin,
Hober Mallow, and the Mule. as she's talking viewers
are introduced to Salvor, the planet Terminus, and
the mysterious Vault that hovers above the ground
there. we see some local kids try to approach it
and get an explanation from Salvor who they refer
to as the warden that the Vault is warning them
to stay away although it's implied that she's not
affected by the null field it generates. right off
the bat you get the idea that the story is going
to be big you're introduced to two timelines
and three planets in the first 10 minutes
the narration shifts from the future to
remembering the past and you meet Hari Seldon
and his adopted son Raych 35 years prior at the
imperial library on the empire's capital planet
Trantor. they're discussing Gaal's arrival and
then we meet her on her homeworld of Synnax you
see her looking at her prayer stones that she
removed before her journey to trantor to meet
Hari these are cultural markers that every member
of the Seer's church has in their cheeks you get
the feeling that her leaving has set her apart
from her people and later learned that math and
science go against their beliefs as you learn more
about her background you find out that the waters
are rising on Synnax threatening their way of life
and the people have turned to faith for answers
this led to the universities being burned down and
a purge of intellectuals Gaal taught herself math
hoping to help save her people she won a contest
by solving a problem called the Abraxas Conjecture
which no one had been able to figure out for
over 500 years after that she gets offered
a job by Hari Seldon and says goodbye to
her parents before leaving Synnax for good
she gets transported to a jump ship which is our
introduction to the hyperspatial travel that made
it possible for humans to settle on habitable
planets throughout the galaxy she meets a man
named Gerrol just before they're put to sleep for
the jump he turns out to be an agent of the empire
that was sent to spy on her he tells her they have
to be put to sleep because sometimes it can feel
like your mind and body are taking different trips
they have to be secured in these pods because the
artificial gravity has to be turned off so they
can navigate the jump for some reason Gaal wakes
up while they're in transit which is strange and
she's immediately sedated by one of the spacers
working on the ship if you're curious as to what
these spacers are I'll come back to them after
the recap when she arrives on Trantor she takes
the star bridge down to the planet and there's a
lot of world building in the details while she's
on her way to meet Raych who takes her to Hari
you learn that billions of people live below
the surface on 100 subterranean levels where
they never see the sun or the stars Trantor is
an ecumenopolis the entire planet is encompassed
by the city as the surface became completely
developed they started to build down and then
they do things like projecting skies overhead
on the lower levels to make it look more natural
Hari asked her some questions about how
she solved the problem in an effort to
get to know her and then he drops it on her
that they're going to be arrested tomorrow
when she asks why he questions if she's familiar
with his work on psycho history he says it's the
destiny of the human race expressed in numbers
when she hears this she asks if they're worried
that he can predict the future and he says that
they're worried that people believe he can and
they don't like the future he predicts he tells
her that Trantor is going to be destroyed and the
empire will fall when he shows her the prime
radiant which is the visual representation of
his equations she realizes that they believe she's
the only one that can prove him wrong Hari agrees
that that's true if he was wrong she would be able
to prove it but he's not this is all bad news for
her she left home where she would have been
arrested only to find out she'll face the same
thing on Trantor on the way out she asks rates to
take her to a Seer church and the priest knows who
she is and he isn't a fan of Seldon's prophecies
either you also meet the genetic dynasty of Dawn,
Day, and Dusk. they're all clones of emperor Cleon
the first who have been ruling for four centuries
you see that they do consider Seldon as a threat
and also that they can be cruel when day kills a
man who's been working for him for over 60 years
just for being in possession of something that
Hari wrote the three versions of the same person
at three different ages have complete control of
the empire. Day sits on the middle throne as the
leader until Dawn grows old enough to take his
place Dusk advises his younger selves and
the cycle continues. Eto Demerzel is their
first minister and appears to assist in managing
everything. on top of going after Hari and Gaal
the Cleons are dealing with a dispute over
resources between two planets that hate each
other Anacreon and Thespis because some agents of
the empire were killed in the dispute they've been
summoned to answer for that and to try to avoid
an all-out war. Gaal and Hari are arrested and
their trial is public regular citizens are able
to watch it with the Cleons watching very closely
Hari explains that psychohistory is a predictive
model designed to forecast the behavior of very
large populations when questioned as to what it
says about the empire he says it's going to fall
in 500 years or possibly sooner they accuse him
of trying to undermine an empire that's existed
for 12 000 years and he pleads that he's not
a revolutionary it's just what the math says
he claims the collapse is too far along it can't
be stopped but they can shorten the 30 000 years
of barbarism that's going to follow it they can
cut that to just 1 000 years. he can't prove any
of this, his predictions can't be checked because
no one really understands the math except for
Gaal. so after the first day of questioning
Gerrol comes back and gives Gaal the prime radiant
he tells her that she has to disavow
Hari and say that his math is wrong
and if for some reason the equations turn out to
be correct the empire will deal with that they'll
fix the problems without terrifying trillions of
people he gives her an ultimatum either she says
that Hari is wrong and he dies and if she doesn't
she dies when she takes the prime radiant back to
her room she's able to activate it and see the
equations in court the next day harry is asked
directly how he would shorten the period of chaos
his plan is to create an encyclopedia galactica
essentially collect all of mankind's knowledge
and then print it and distribute it after the
fall a new empire will rise from the ashes and
this will serve as a foundation of knowledge
for them to build upon when they call Gaal to
testify she goes against the empire verifying
that Seldon's math is correct and she confirms
that the empire is dying as they're leaving the
courtroom she senses that something's wrong
with the star bridge and tells harry about it
then it cuts to two simultaneous suicide bomber
attacks on the bridge and the platform you see
it kill everyone there as it falls out of orbit
to wrap around the planet tearing 50 levels down
there's a hundred million people dead and there's
a fear that the outer reaches may be in rebellion
Raych gives Gaal a chance to give Hari up but she
refuses and they're taken in front of the emperor
Hari's work has convinced him that things are
going to get worse so the star bridge attack isn't
a surprise he doesn't say that he predicted that
that would happen specifically but it sounds like
he knew something would and he explains he can't
figure out who did it because he can't predict
individual's actions and then when asked if the
fall can be slowed down he says yes they need to
end the genetic dynasty Dusk gets angry about
that saying that the dynasty stopped the wars
Hari stands by it he says that change will help
things but there's no movement on either side
when they ask why they shouldn't just kill Hari
Gaal steps in and says that it would actually speed
things up that she saw that when she looked at
the equations she says that Hari's hope and if
they kill hope then the people will kill them when
they're alone together gail realizes the contest
was set up to find someone that could understand
Seldon's equations he just reached out and got to
her before they did they're brought back in and
told that the decision is to let them continue
their work on psychohistory but not on Trantor
they're being allowed to travel by slow ship to
an uninhabited planet called Terminus which of
course we saw at the beginning without a jump ship
the trip will take them years they've been exiled
and if psychohistory turns out to be fraudulent
then the foundation will just be allowed to wither
and if it's useful the empire can just co-opt it
for themselves Terminus is on the periphery
and it neighbors the two kingdoms that are
apparently behind the starbridge attack on the
way out gail begins to realize that exile was
always Hari's plan he says the planet is perfect
for what they need to do and that's the twist
is that even though he was gambling to a certain
extent on these things everything had been planned
in advance and it did work out how he expected he
tells her you came here to save your world why not
think bigger save the galaxy and then it cuts to
terminus 35 years later the narration picks back
up saying no one could approach the vault except
for an outlier like Salvor Hardin Gaal says she
always wondered if when Hari was formulating
the plan did he realize the galaxy's fate would
rest on what she found inside she thinks he did
and thinks that's what he feared the most in the
beginning of episode 2 the Cleon still can't
figure out who contracted the people who were
responsible for the star bridge attack Demerzel's
looking into it she goes to a biohacking place
at one point and without anything else to go on
brother day still just kind of wants to kill Hari
but Demerzel won't let it happen because she
knows there's nothing to connect him to the crime
both Anacreon and Thespis deny being involved and
that seems like they're probably telling the truth
they hate each other so it doesn't really make
sense for them to collaborate on the attack we see
that Dusk is getting old and we see that there's a
natural tension that exists between him and day we
can imagine that this probably always happens and
he goes to see the seer priest at the church that
Gaal went to where he sees the destruction of what
happened firsthand he's trying to find out if Gaal
is a Seer based on the weird stuff we've seen
around her it's an interesting question while
they're there Demerzel gets hit by a falling rock
and then later we see brother Dawn watching as
she repairs herself and that she's revealed to
be a robot and you may have noticed that there
aren't any real robots around in Trantor as it is
brother Dawn says that all of her kind had died
and she corrects him saying they didn't die they
were destroyed by his kind so she does her best
to act like a human and at this point it's not
really clear how well her true identity is covered
up after talking to the Anacreon and the Thespin
they have in their custody dust decides that mercy
is the right way to go brother Day doesn't listen
and decides to make an example of the outer worlds
he sends ships to attack the planet and then
executes the members of the delegation who
came to Trantor but leaves the two leaders alive
to go back and tell their people how they failed
there's a teaching moment here for brother Dawn
Demerzel tells him it won't always be like this
when he asks exactly how often do they choose
to do things like this she just says you always
do on the slow ship Gaal and Raych started
a relationship that's getting serious and
you learn that there's four months and four years
left of the trip you see that everyone's getting
prepared to live they're learning new skills you
meet some of the new characters that would still
be around in Salvor's timeline if nothing else
the colonists look serious they believe that
the empire is going to fall and what they're doing
is going to be very important with the foundation
to preserve knowledge and rebuild the civilization
there's a side story here about a pregnancy that
Gaal's involved in it appears that women who get
pregnant opt to preserve that until after they
make it to Terminus so it makes you wonder if Raych
and Gaal won't be the parents of somebody who
turns out to be important and i guess it should
be noted that salvor hardin isn't born yet we do
see the two characters here that are cast to play
her parents when they're much younger than what
they'll be in that timeline but otherwise i don't
see how this pregnancy thing is really essential
if it's not going to pay off later either way
they're trying to hide the relationship from Hari
and in his interactions you can see that he
realizes that the foundation is going to be
successful at least the plan is fully in motion
but that his time with it is coming to an end
the calculations show that it's going to be a
tough road for the people who are left behind
something like a mortality rate of 34.2 percent
after five years on terminus although he says this
is trending downward so their training is working
in their conversation there's also a mention of
the robot wars and the hanging of AI sympathizers
in an orchard in the imperial gardens this all
refers back to what Demerzel was telling brother
dawn about her kind being destroyed by humans the
episode comes to an end as Gaal's following her
normal routine she's in the pool swimming and then
she gets a feeling that something's wrong and
decides to leave she goes looking for Raych and
can't find him and that leads her to Hari's room
where she sees Raych stabbing him and taking his
life we also see that rach takes something
from behind his ear before he goes after her
and then he puts her in a pod throwing his knife
inside telling her that he loves her and then he
launches it the pod seems to be programmed and it
looks like she's probably being put to sleep for
a period of time it's definitely not clear if her
interrupting what happened in Hari's room is why
she's on the pod as all of her interactions
with Hari earlier made it seem like he was
grooming her to be the leader on Terminus he even
sent her to that meeting to sit in in his place
it's definitely possible that she interrupted
because of that feeling she had and then Raych had
to change his plan which we're gonna have to wait
and see what was really going on with that because
all of his interactions with harry portrayed them
having a close and loving relationship there was
the awkward interaction at dinner we hadn't seen
anything like that between them before everything
we'd seen from Raych was that he was concerned even
though he might not have been a hundred percent
positive that Hari was right and there definitely
are seeds planted there where it could go the
other way Gaal telling him that the math wasn't
complete and it's a pretty good cliffhanger when
you think about it like that so i'm excited to
see where it goes in the next episode so to wrap
it all up Hari used psychohistory to forecast
the fall of the empire he believes what the math
is telling him and knows that the Cleons will
never give up their power willingly by solving
abraxas when no one else could Gaal is considered
the best person to check if his work is correct
she gets pulled into the situation she decides
to go against the empire and this all leads to
all these people on the slow ship being exiled to
terminus to create the foundation there's quite a
few mysteries to think about first and foremost
who's really behind the attack on the starbridge
it definitely doesn't seem like the people
that are being punished are the ones who did it
which means there could be blowback from that but
also that there could be another force in play
Gaal has plenty of mysteries around her too this
idea that she senses things why did she wake up
during the jump where did she go at the end is
she hibernating and for how long what was the
significance of the zygote scene is part of the
reason that they gender swapped this character
because she's going to have descendants on
terminus why did rach kill Hari that feels like
it was part of the plan rather than some murderous
rage but then how did Gaal walking in change
things what was the device he took from behind
Hari's ear what's going on with the vault how
did it get there because it seems beyond Hari's
natural skill set although he did have a lot of
people working for him and what's going on with
the Cleons having a robot they kept Demerzel
mostly in the background in these two episodes but
even if you don't know anything about the books
i'm sure she's starting to pique your interest as
for a review it looks really fantastic and that's
super promising for it being around long enough
to turn into something that will be remembered
as a great tv series sci-fi of this scale is
tough to pull off and there's a balance with
all the necessary worldbuilding you have to do in
the beginning to set the stage with it not being
overwhelming and finding something compelling
something watchable to hook viewers in. in this
case you're also working with the book series
that people won't want to see changed in any way
for that reason I tried to watch this without
comparing it too much to the books since in my
opinion there are some obvious problems in making
an overly faithful adaptation for tv generally i
think the creators took most of those things into
account and came up with clever solutions it turns
out though that the trick is to make those changes
where they don't disrupt the big ideas behind the
original every change you make affects the rest
of the story and only time will tell if they'll
be able to pull that off the solution to make the
emperor's clones is a novel idea and you can't go
wrong with Lee Pace and i especially like the
idea that even though they're all copies of the
same man they still want to distinguish themselves
and we're just gonna have to see where they take
the genetic dynasty as there's really no reason
to think they're gonna give up power or that the
people on terminus would be able to undermine that
anytime soon a lot of what i liked about the books
is the way that people who don't understand
the plan they're following react to that
and then the bigger ideas about what is the right
way to create a new civilization personalities
present themselves at the right time but none
of the characters are important in the long run
beyond the situation that they're faced with so
it comes off a little strange when you introduce
ideas around characters being special changing it
up isn't necessarily bad but hopefully it won't
take away from the original story's appeal after
watching the first two episodes i'm dazzled by
the visuals and most of the performances and feel
optimistic overall i think it was a good start and
even if everything doesn't work out in the first
season it's comforting knowing that there's still
a lot of good story they can draw from in the
future one thing that stands out as a big question
mark for me is Demerzel being involved in killing
based on the three laws of robotics i know there's
the zeroth law but they're gonna have to address
this at some point i mentioned that i would come
back to the spacers it's not clear what they're
doing with them here they almost look like robots
in asimov's robot series spacers are people who
decided that they wanted to live away from earth
after hyperspatial travel became common this is a
real simplification but humans became divided into
two groups the people on earth at that time they
were sort of anti-robot they wanted things to stay
more or less the same and the spacers wanted to go
out and colonize and become something different i
also mentioned how Gaal's narration was from
the perspective of the future in the books we
had excerpts from the encyclopedia galactica
the same book that they go to terminus to create
so those give historical accounts from a time
later about what's going on in the actual timeline
so that's a neat nod the way that they did
that with the obvious change that some of these
characters are going to be around longer than
just the period of time where they're introduced
they kept Hari seldon mostly the same his
characterization what he was trying to do that all
sticks pretty close to the books where you see the
differences and it would take a whole other video
to actually point all those out is where they're
giving these other characters a story in an effort
to try to get us to care about them and i think
that's a good place to leave things let me know in
the comments what you think if you want to include
things about the book series please mark those
we don't want to spoil it for everyone else let
me know any theories that you came up with how
you think things might play out please like
this video if you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon